a power blackout had left the Buddha
town of pondwe in darkness when armed
men attacked
students say they were sleeping when
Allied Democratic forces forced their
way into hostels stole food from a store
and burned a dormitory
some of the students were hacked to
death with machetes and axes others were
killed when the rebels detonated a bomb
some survived by hiding under the bodies
of their dead fellow students we were
getting ready to sleep when we heard
people shouting we saw men wearing dark
green clothes with guns axes and
machetes they wanted us to open the
dormitory door then they started
shooting they also went to the girls
hostels
Ugandan forces are pursuing the rebels
who are believed to have fled into the
virunga national park in eastern
Democratic Republic of Congo ADF is
based in Benny territory in North kivu
province that borders Dr Congo and
Western Uganda
we have sent helicopters to look for the
rebels and bring back the children who
have been abducted
the group had its roots in Western
Uganda in the 1990s where it was
fighting for more rights for Muslims it
was pushed out of the country by the
military changed its name and has been
in Benny for more than 20 years and
recently pledged allegiance to isil the
Ugandan government with their Congolese
Partners have uh
establish what they call operation suja
which is a military joint military
operation against the ADF and in the
past few months we have seen a major
Onslaught by operation tutor around
mualica avadi against the ADF and when
they are under this kind of pressure
they then stuck at a start attacking
civilians
While most of the attacks have been on
Congolese soil
Uganda has seen an increase in ADF
activity in recent years
that included a suicide bomb attack in a
business district of the capital Kampala
two years ago that killed three people
and injured others
attacks such as those have prompted both
governments in Uganda and DRC to do more
to prevent a repeat Catherine soy Al
Jazeera